okay guys I've heard you okay
I understand they listen hold on hold on
hold on hold on young lady yeah young
lady don't just don't don't just don't
just don't just start yelling young
ladies
hey sir Sir sir what of this so you sir
Sir sir why'd you sit down sir all right
listen
yeah baby here okay can I just say this
all right I've listened to you I heard
you I heard you I heard you all right
now I've been respectful I'll let you
holler
so let me
no but nobody's removing you I've heard
you but you've got a lesson to meet you
alright so I understand you may disagree
I understand you may disagree but we've
got to be able to talk honestly about
these issues all right
although I disagree with some of your
characterizations it doesn't make much
sense to yell at me right now when we're
making changes so hey
some planners
but the point is let's make sure that
let's make sure that you get the facts
and that you know exactly what we're
doing and then if you have disagreements
then you can work through all the
immigrants rights organizations that we
work with to try to address some of your
concerns right so but what but what but
what what but here's what won't work
well won't work is folks what won't work
is folks just shouting at each other all
right so be I've been respectful I've
responded your question I'd ask you now
to let me speak to all the other people
who are here all right
even okay it's good to be back in
Chicago
so because everybody's got something to
say